[Musica]
come avete dormito questa notte quando
dormite dormite bene quante volte vi è
capitato di svegliarvi più stanchi della
sera prima
vi siete mai chiesti che cosa accadde in
quelle otto ore che dedichiamo al sonno
otto ore al giorno sono un terzo della
nostra vita
un terzo della nostra vita per avere
un'idea e per una persona di 50 anni
l'arco temporale di 18 anni come se ci
si svegliasse già maggiorenni per ognuno
di noi ogni giornata è influenzato da
come abbiamo dormito
pensate a quando chiudiamo gli occhi e
ci addormentiamo entriamo in una
dimensione in cui siamo tutti uguali
uomini donne ricchi poveri ma non è così
per tutti c'è una percentuale di persone
circa il 10 per cento della popolazione
per la quale durante il sonno si
manifestano delle problematiche e lo
rendono inefficace ci si sveglia stanchi
affaticati ed è difficile pensare agire
avere una vita sociale normale lavorare
quel giorno 11 anni fa sono stata
travolta da una grande e inaspettata
delusione professionale dopo un attimo
di sconforto e di rabbia ho deciso di
dedicare le mie energie e la mia
professionalità ad un settore che in
italia era ancora poco sviluppato cosa
sta facendo questa persona dorme quindi
non fa nulla verrebbe da dire invece in
quelle otto ore in cui pensiamo di
staccare la spina nel nostro organismo
avvengono una serie di eventi che sono
fondamentali per la nostra salute
per la nostra qualità di vita e per
quella di chi ci circonda
se dormiamo male il corpo ne risente
rimaniamo stanchi durante la giornata e
non sappiamo perché negli ultimi
vent'anni la medicina ha dedicato sempre
maggiore attenzione ai disturbi del
sonno e in particolare ai disturbi
respiratori del sonno
nonostante ciò in italia la patologia
ancora decisamente sotto diagnosticata
questo per un problema di mancanza di
risorse
ci sono quindi dei costi sanitari e
sociali importanti a causa di queste
politiche
si stima che ci siano circa 4 milioni di
italiani che soffrono di disturbi del
sonno e non sono trattati perché non
hanno una diagnosi
questo nonostante la tecnologia oggi
consenta dei nuovi protocolli grazie
alla telemedicina grazie alla
miniaturizzazione dei dispositivi
undici anni fa ho fondato in italia
grazie al supporto di un'azienda
francese una azienda che affianca medici
specialisti nella gestione strumentale
tecnica dei loro pazienti con disturbi
respiratori del sonno
abbiamo creato uno staff di tecnici
competenti aperto una sede e poi anche
altre creato un messaggio e un identità
e costruito delle sinergie con dei
fornitori e sul territorio tutto questo
per portare a domicilio la
polisonnografia la polisonnografia o
monitoraggio cardio respiratori del
sonno e l'esame diagnostico strumentale
per individuare le famigerate apnee
notturne è un esame non invasivo che si
fa direttamente a domicilio dormendo nel
proprio letto e monitora una serie di
parametri fisiologici
viene poi interpretato da
un tecnico e refertato da un medico ci
dice se abbiamo un problema è la gravità
eventualmente di quel problema
nel fare questo a volte siamo stati
considerati un po pionieri perché
eravamo i primi sembrava una cosa
difficile
altri poi ci hanno seguito qualcuno c'è
poi copiato ma questo credo che sia ciò
che accade alle buone idee
nonostante ciò ancora oggi non è così
comune percepire che respirare male
durante il sonno rappresenta un problema
è un pericolo per la salute
russare è ancora considerata una cosa
buffa al limite fastidiosa per il nostro
compagno di letto
si chiama sindrome delle apnee
ostruttive del sonno e ha delle
conseguenze cliniche documentate tra cui
disturbi cardiovascolari come ictus
l'ipertensione dismetabolismi come
diabete di tipo 2 ha delle correlazioni
con l'insorgenza dell'obesità perché
durante il sonno al nostro organismo
produce gli ormoni della fame della
sazietà e se l'architettura del sonno e
disordinata la produzione di queste
sostanze non è adeguata
ci sono poi delle correlazioni già
dimostrate con l'insorgenza per esempio
dell'alzheimer e di alcune forme di
tumore
inoltre è anche dimostrata una
correlazione tra la scarsità di sonno
una cattiva qualità del sonno e una
cattiva risposta immunitaria
ci sono poi delle conseguenze
neurologiche come la scarsa capacità di
concentrazione durante il giorno la
sonnolenza la
difficoltà di memoria disturbi
dell'umore fino alle rush abilità e alla
depressione essere stanchi durante il
giorno percepire sonnolenza inficia
anche la nostra attività quotidiane
diventa difficile lavorare e avere una
vita sociale normale è anche difficile
guidare si stima per esempio che nei
soli stati uniti circa 100 mila
incidenti all'anno siano causati dal
colpo di sonno
in italia ci sono una serie di studi tra
i quali uno dell'associazione nazionale
delle imprese di assicurazione che parla
di un quarto degli incidenti stradali
causato dal colpo di sonno
e poi c'è un capitolo della medicina del
lavoro dedicato alle problematiche del
sonno
esistono dei casi storici eclatanti ad
esempio l'incidente della petroliera
exxon valdez che nel 1989 sverso
nell'oceano atlantico 50 milioni di
litri di petrolio inquinando 1.900
chilometri di coste in alaska
fu un disastro ambientale e la causa è
stata evidenziata come una scarsa
reattività del comandante ad un comando
per cambiare rotta si incagliò contro
una scogliera anche l'incidente nucleare
di chernobyl dell 86 a una concausa
errore umano e sonno questo perché gli
addetti ai controlli non ebbero
prontezza di riflessi adeguata
quando ci prendiamo cura di una persona
con dei disturbi del sonno non ci
prendiamo cura solo della sua salute
quindi ma dell'intera comunità
che cosa significa prendersi cura
significa fare una corretta diagnosi e
poi consentire a questa persona di
accedere a dei percorsi terapeutici le
terapie sono diverse la più conosciuta è
la c pap
l'aci pappe l'acronimo inglese significa
ventilazione a pressione positiva
continua ed è una macchinetta che si
mette sul comodino durante la notte
collegata tramite un tubo e una
mascherina consente al paziente di
respirare meglio
ho visto personalmente pazienti passare
da 80 apnea allora a 2 e mi hanno
raccontato di sentirsi completamente
rinati perché finalmente avevano dormito
nei bambini le apnee del sonno portano
difficoltà di concentrazione e disturbi
dell'apprendimento
purtroppo è un tema ancora poco
conosciuto e mi è capitato ancora di
recente sentire delle mamme parlando del
sonno del proprio bambino affermare non
ho ma mio figlio dorme profondamente
russa come suo nonno e magari non è
proprio una cosa bella per tornare alle
esperienze imprenditoriali posso dire
dopo dieci anni che è stata sicuramente
un'esperienza fino ad oggi fortunata e
forse anche di successo penso che la mia
passione e il mio entusiasmo siano la
forza trainante per tutti i miei
collaboratori e credo di aver realizzato
un sogno
la cosa che mi piace pensare è che tra
tutte le persone a cui abbiamo
contribuito a risolvere un problema del
sonno
magari ci sia qualcuno che avendo
ritrovato forza ed energia durante le
sue giornate sia in grado di realizzare
un sogno tutto suo
c'è un detto che dice chi dorme non
piglia pesci e io l'ho trasformato chi
dorme bene costruisce pescherecci
grazie